yeah I mean South Africa's a really
interesting case right now because I
think politically what's happening is in
the next couple in the next fortnight
actually a new African National Congress
president will be elected and whoever
becomes president of the ANC effectively
becomes president of the country because
they get sort of sixty-five percent of
the vote in any national election and
the front-runner at the moment is this
this guy Jacob Zuma who was deputy
president and then got fired because he
said he was charged with both rape and
corruption he got acquitted on the rape
charge but said the most horrific
misogynistic things during the trial and
the corruption charges been sort of put
off and put off and put off in here
something you know some funny business
going on there but the reason he is
interesting is he has massive popular
support among low low low class and
South Africans who I think feel that you
know it's been too long since 94 and
they're not seeing the kind of practical
material changes in their lives you know
houses running water electricity and and
so there's a kind of radicalism that's
sort of being fostered at that level and
for some reason Zuma has captured the
imagination of these people and he is
not being seen as the antidote to the
kind of politicians like him becuse the
current president or a lot of the
extremely wealthy black businessmen like
Tokyo 6-wire he's a basically a mining
magnate so I think it's a what's coming
to a head nod South Africa is this thing
of you know what happened is a lot of
the wealth was just sort of transferred
from this tranche of elite white to
elite blacks and the people on the
ground saw nothing change in their lives
and so there's a there's a kind of a
backlash against that and so it's
playing out
all along class lines now then it is
along race lines race is still used as a
galvanizing factor politically so you
know Zuma will often I think use white
as scapegoats to sort of get people you
know riled up but really it's an issue
of feeling like not enough has happened
to kind of change the economics of the
country in a way that benefits ordinary
South Africans that makes them sound
like a much better person than years I
mean I think this is one of the things
that worries me a lot at the moment it's
like watching a train smash about to
happen and the global community doesn't
really seem to see how terrible it would
be if he becomes president I mean
there's nothing you can do but I think
if he became president South Africa
would go the way of Zimbabwe within five
to ten years I think he would do a land
grab I think he would nationalize all
sorts of things but I think he's a
leader who has absolutely no no qualms
about you know doing what is best for
him and
you